i noticed is this something you picked
up from takashi going at all these
rappers
and essentially being like you ain't
gonna do [ __ ] like when you went at meek
he was doing it first you went at were
you doing that first or was that
no i'm gonna be honest i've always had
like but it was more of a
it was more of a challenging dialogue
right i think now you know what i mean
like i just don't realize how stupid it
is that's what 69 didn't expose
like they ain't going to do [ __ ] that's
what i'm asking
that's what i mean they're going to do
[ __ ] bro like he definitely supposed yo
i used to think these dudes were killers
i'm like yo a [ __ ] like me gotta have
like 40 bodies nobody knows about is
buried somewhere like in oklahoma this
guy's
yo you hear he's rapping he's the then
you see these dudes like swing like
you see the punch in the back you're
like hold on this is not a killer no
you got to be a shooter this guy's this
guy's a killer and then you realize like
yo in reality all the rappers who are
killers
they go to jail like really quickly like
yeah everybody
else really considers themselves as a
brand and
working in media you started seeing how
fake this [ __ ] was one of the first
times
meek mill ever you know
him and his team got mad at me i posted
a video this is how much they want to
keep their gangsta
image i posted a video of meek mill in
the hood right he goes back to philly
after
a while there was a big ass block party
i guess
out of the shot fired or something like
that
sent me a video of six armed
police officers off duty of course who
are working security for him
with their guns drawn and they have him
in the middle like he's [ __ ] trump or
[ __ ] biden
and i posted i said hey meet uh uh
meek mill being being um secured by his
security after you know there was like a
fight or whatever the cases
they hit me yo take that i'm like wait
what
now they gave me the most [ __ ]
reason oh not as probations probation
i'm like
you know on instagram the whole time
showing y'all at the location
why can't this party show the
facade that they're giving you is that
these dudes are killers
yeah for six nine to still be alive
after this long
says something right uh there's some
credibility to what you're saying but at
the same time you
know it's not all fluff because you do
keep your location secretive for that
purpose so they can't catch up to you no
well hear what i'm saying though the
people and you don't tell people where
you live
no but i'm talking about like he won't
even like geotag where he's at or stuff
like that because he knows people are
looking for him
no no like if he if you walked in philly
right now talking about
aren't rappers yeah but you know what
you know that that's that's what man
he exposed he didn't like even when i
know people are saying he exposed
chicago nah it's not chicago
he was trying to expose the chicago
rappers he was trying to expose
particular rappers and
what people don't want to admit in rap
is that these dudes are multi-million
dollar brands
yeah and they rap like they're murderers
and they act like they would throw it
away for nothing
yeah they won't that's a part of the
brand it's like hey listen
whether and to be honest you get to a
certain level
like meek mill could roll around with 30
people like yeah if i have
no security and i run into meek mill
with his 30 paid goons
it might be a problem yeah yeah but am i
really like
thinking meek is a killer he's not do
you think meek mill is a killer
let me ask you a question i do think he
did stuff in his past he has okay he's a
multi
we don't care about his past that sounds
cute he went to jail he went back to
jail for wheelie and then he started
crying
now he's free wow now to be honest with
you
i mean no no no no no i feel you i had
to i had to evaluate
i had to like there was a point where i
realized
the moment the moment i realized that
what you're scared of with rappers i
could also do bro
you think i don't got the same amount of
money to have 30 people walk around and
go every single place with me no
i feel that but i'm saying you know how
it's not we would be calling the rappers
stupid if they're out doing the stuff
that they're rapping about but their
goons around them is the
people who are supposed to take care of
it so it's like there's going to be
somebody who just wants to get meek's
mill
favor and be like yo i got at and he
won't even be
meek's man but he'll just stall off on
you and be like yo meek i got him for
you
okay like you know that could happen now
now you're right about that
but i was supposed to be scared of meat
mode for that that could happen anywhere
i could say something about any rapper
and i don't even know the person has a
problem and then
hasn't happened that's a super fan it
could happen but it's not what i'm
trying to say is that
i don't know we as fans because fans are
scared of the rapper you're scared of
that rapper yo yo the guy who works for
meek doesn't want to lose his job either
especially not for catching a body for
for what academics he's saying meek
don't want to go back to jail just uh
neither does it matter neither does the
security guard that gets the [ __ ]
[ __ ] on the side with me
that gets a tour around the world with
me that gets to go to sixers games with
me
you think he's risking all that shoot at
no mika's hanging with billionaires yeah
it's a different world bro
yo the only thing what i realize in
terms of the industry
if i was beefing with some some hood
[ __ ] who really didn't have them to
lose
i would be really scared mm-hmm i
realize these things are brands
and i know bro i'm male 1
robert i've literally been in a
situation where i told my guy i said
please don't do nothing because they
don't say i did it
i don't move around like that i don't
want nobody swinging on nobody on behalf
of me that's not my thing
so when you have money power and
influence and especially you're in
hip-hop
there's oh and you have an entourage
that's the job of the entourage
but that's not be so it the fans think
that you're scared of the rapper
that's not the case there's certain
rappers they're actually still living
like they're ghosts who
who should i see he's in jail he was in
the club somebody like apparently like
pickpocketing for 40k i don't know how
that happens
and he takes out a gun he takes out a
gun
like what i'm trying to say is that oh
the only the
idiotic rappers are still operating like
their goons and
69 did help expose that because
well and that's why the casual fan i
think loves him
because the casual right that not not
the person that's from the streets the
person who's not from the streets
wants to believe that all those people
talking that street [ __ ] that they're
intimidated
of are lying yo don't you want to
believe that the people that you're
scared of are full of [ __ ]
yo you hear what i'm saying i remember
because i used to i was trying to talk
nine
but he's also he's like yo stop thinking
everybody's these killers
and i think his perspective was he was
rolling with a bunch of dudes
who literally were trying to kill people
and i think he was like hey i'm in this
young part of my career
and i see the risk of actually having
having these people around like for
example i remember telling myself yo
first of all it's a conflict of also
interest i'm like yo i love chief keef
please leave chief keef alone don't be
with chief
also the internet narrative is that
chief keef is one of the most ruthless
humans on earth yeah yeah
is he now here's the thing for him he's
like
what chief keith came to new york
and this is all this is documented in
court everybody it's cool
dude shot at chief keef he's like if
he's the root this guy we're shooting at
him what's going on
and then i think for the fans they're
like
wait how does how does this happen
and i do think that's what i was saying
about rappers
certain rappers are like that but most
rappers they're brands bro
and and i know listen to a gangster
rapper rap gangsta music
we want to be so married to the
lifestyle that you think they're doing
it
you forget that they're managing a
multi-million dollar brand
that only a few and only the stupid ones
would jeopardize
like yeah i don't disagree and even i
wouldn't jeopardize my bread like you
think
if meek mill was really a killer meek
mill would have been done some to me
i'm telling you but if he did he would
jeopardize
everything he got going on so what i'm
saying even the android point real quick
even the entourage point if you got
using his word a multi-million dollar
brand
you can't have an employee what happens
when employees say some [ __ ] that's
a part of nike they cut that
[ __ ] loose you can't do that
around me
you got to have your [ __ ] tight if
you're in my entourage yeah you need
professional intel
yes no what i'm just speaking to is that
it's not tough for act to call out meek
isn't it going to do anything to him to
jeopardize that's his point
yeah but i'm saying it like it's not
this that's his i could call on me
i could call out meek i would never go
to philly and be like yo oh yeah
gangster philly's [ __ ]
no yeah never yeah ever
but me meekman don't even be in philly
meanwhile flying around on
private jets and helicopters going to
michael rubin's house and goddamn um
what's the other dude that owns the uh
robert robert like
but i'm saying that rappers live and
they
benefit and profit off the facade the
perception
right yes in his previous life
he used to do a lot of those things yeah
yeah at this point coming out of jail
do you really think and i think that's
the point okay so i'm with you on that
so 69 sees this he understands okay
these guys are million dollar brands and
they have to operate like brands like
the street [ __ ] is i want to get engaged
anybody who doesn't do that
or go to jail like 69 did like 100 if
they didn't go to jail
ask yourself what are they doing young
boys i think in jail now right
anybody who does that go to jail yeah so
you've been listen
if your favorite gangsta rap have been
rapping about killing people for the
last 20 years
yeah yeah and he don't even have a
jaywalking ticket
he exposed that part of it okay so when
he decides to beef
is he simply going okay i need to stir
up the internet let me start talking
some [ __ ] about somebody who says
they're super thug but i know they're
not yeah
simple that's it or is it is it more
methodical
because you know uh he has a recent
issue with little dirk
and i hate it yeah because you know one
of my favorite rappers
is king vaughn and he passed away yeah
yeah and i consistently tell him i'm
like hey first of all
king bond pass you can't keep dissing
them yeah like
what's your issue and i and i even i
haven't told them i'm like maybe you do
need a little bit of therapy because
i think the beef in that first was was
you know you just responded and it hit
in his mind is that
i'm doing my thing but i've never just
dissed you randomly uh i'm just because
you talking i'm responding
yeah i'm responding because you randomly
said [ __ ] me yeah yeah
and because you just said [ __ ] me now
it's on forever
don't get mad at 50 to say this
they they look at 50 was like yo they
look at me
i have to shoot the [ __ ] but
nobody saw me step on my shoe
so and his thing was like don't judge
the response
when you didn't have the same energy for
the person
kicked it off yeah and i think that's
how he still views it
um it's always i remember even what's
the dirk thing explain dirk
so him a little dirk i i i think
there was pretty much almost no issue
and dirk was almost kind of in the
middle
when it came to um his issue with chief
keith
and all of a sudden when he gets locked
up he's now labeled as a snitch
you know dirk chose he he's like all
right
he's going to stay away clearly right
dirk never really dissed him right
but i think number one he signed king
von
king rapped about him and it was like a
rapper was like yo
69 said he seemed it you know and i
think he talked about him a
couple of times on live and i think for
six nine it was just like
hey if if if you like me just ignore me
but if you comment on me and it's
negative i'm gonna have to say something
yeah
and um he went at both of them and i and
i think what happened truthfully i think
dirk took that energy and he blew up
dirk's one of the biggest artists in the
game right now
yeah and um i told him that i said yo
he harnessed your energy he didn't
respond to you
yeah and at the moment
when you were getting blackballed
you got everybody yeah yeah to support
him
yeah because it was the antithesis of
you yeah
it's kind of like what happened with
rory and maul and joe yeah
yeah that's one of the reasons why this
this is gonna be the last time i
mentioned it
yeah yeah yeah yeah unless i'm you know
i mean checking the accountant oh my man
alex over there
we gotta check the account stop
i gave him my email he gonna send me the
uh he's gonna send me the no
the excel spreadsheet we gotta look at
it
bro we gotta take a look with the books
how much are they paying we gotta know
like you were saying yeah
i got you
you